hey crazies time is pretty fundamental
to the universe
it allows for a sequence of events
one causes another which causes another
in an endless chain of cause and effect
cosmically speaking all humans live in a
shared now
but when you stop and think about it
that is inconsistent with time zones
if you're in new york it's three hours
earlier in la
in south korea it's 13 hours ahead it's
tomorrow
but if you call a friend in la you're
not calling three hours ago if you call
south korea you're not calling tomorrow
how do these two concepts of time
coexist in our minds
[Music]
many of us have this issue where we have
to switch our clocks twice a year for me
it happens in march and november and
frankly it's a pain in the butt like
every time my sleep schedule is a wreck
for a week
and i took a poll so i know i'm not
alone in this but the fact that we can
do this with our clocks at all just goes
to show how arbitrary these numbers are
time doesn't care what we label 9 am or
6 pm it doesn't care whether we call it
october or skeletor there are 10 days
missing from october 1582 and everything
is fine
but even if we stop switching our clocks
twice a year we still have one more
problem left
time zones
that's when our clocks change from place
to place which is also ridiculous
i mean look at this map
one glance and you can tell this mess
isn't scientific it's political
all because we want our clocks to
vaguely match the position of the sun in
the sky
why does sunrise need to happen at 6am
give or take a couple hours why do
office jobs have to be nine to five
everywhere
yeah what's the deal with not right now
question clone i'm having a moment okay
it's okay if i just
yeah yeah i'll call you if i need you
where was i
oh right
cosmically speaking it's the same time
all over the world yet our clocks say
otherwise
why because tradition tradition
long before we understood the
fundamental nature of time we saw
patterns in the world around us
the sun rises in the morning and it sets
in the evening
the moon goes through phases
there are four temperate seasons
fall winter spring and summer or if you
live in michigan almost winter winter
still winter and construction my point
is humans are observant creatures these
patterns were not only interesting they
were useful
we could use them to measure the passage
of time at least vaguely eventually
though we would want to be a bit more
specific and that would take some
ingenuity
to the timeline
around 3500 bce egypt babylon and china
had obelisks with shadows that told the
time
by 1 500 bce the design was refined into
the sundials we recognized today
the shadow essentially acts like the
hour hand on a clock
these devices give us something we now
call apparent solar time
but for most of human history apparent
solar time was just the time
time was determined by the sun
which i guess kind of makes sense given
how long ago this was
solar patterns told us when to plant
crops and when to hunt the sun was the
best source of light we had to conduct
our lives
sure we could build a fire but that's
not nearly as bright as the sun
as the ages went on though we built
better clocks and things started to
change
the first mechanical clock would appear
around 725 ce in china it was water
powered though so it had limitations
the first weight powered clock wouldn't
arrive until 1283 at a monastery in
england
this clock was so regular the design
became all the rage in europe over the
next century
but people still considered the sun to
be the real time
so even though mechanical clocks were
already more regular than the sun they
were considered inaccurate
tradition
anyway let's take a moment to get some
perspective on how ridiculous everyone
was being
we'd like to think of a day as one full
rotation of the earth which isn't true
actually that's a bit dismissive that is
something we call a sidereal day
cider meaning star
it's how long it would take your point
on the earth to once again be facing the
same distant stars it's about 23 hours
and 56 minutes long but that's not the
only definition for a day and it's not
the one most people use
when the sun is highest in the sky we
call that local noon
that's when the sun is due south for the
northern hemisphere and due north for
the southern hemisphere
you could define a day as local noon to
local noon
we call that a solar day
as the earth spins it also revolves
around the sun
for the sun to be in the same place in
the sky the next day the earth has to
rotate just a little bit more than you'd
expect
you might guess this extra little bit is
4 minutes long which would take our 23
hour 56 minute sidereal day and make it
a 24 24-hour solar day but you'd be
wrong
solar days aren't always the same length
they would be if earth didn't have an
axial tilt and its orbit was perfectly
circular but no earth's got to go and
make things all complicated the axial
tilt makes solar days longer near the
solstices and shorter near the equinoxes
to make matters worse earth's orbit is
slightly elliptical which means the
orbital speed is faster in january and
slower in july
this was no big deal when everyone was
using sundials we just accepted that's
how time worked but everyone had since
upgraded to mechanical clocks and making
one of those match the irregular sun is
impractical at best
so the powers that be found a cheat
averages
the length of the solar day may change
throughout the year but they could just
take an average of those and call it a
day
get it
call it a day
such a torque
i mean literally that average is called
the mean solar day
otherwise known as 24 hours
this means solar day is what us modern
people would consider to be a day
it's not astronomical motion it's
completely invented
but that means it doesn't match the sun
you may or may not have seen an image
like this before it's called a solar
graph it shows the path of the sun in
the sky throughout a year
according to apparent solar time the
sundial time the sun is always highest
in the sky
according to mean solar time the time on
your clock this is where the sun is at
various noons throughout the year
it forms a shape known as an analemma
it is a closed shape though so things
average out
now what they did back in the 1300s is
they mapped out all of those variations
and called it the equation of time
mind you this isn't something a regular
person was using to fix their own clock
most people didn't have their own clocks
usually the local church had a clock and
that was it
this graph shows the correction they
would have to make when setting the
clock at the church
because remember the sundial time is the
real time
humans are so stubborn
tradition
so yeah i mean it took some time but we
did eventually let sundials go
in 1656 christian hawkins built the
first pendulum clock it was a hundred
times more precise than its weight
driven predecessors
so by 1670 the minute hand became a
standard clock component
the second hand wouldn't become popular
for another 200 years or so
and this is right around when time zones
became a thing
[Music]
hello
hey it's mr beat oh hey matt
railroads
what
railroads are the reason why we first
needed time zones
oh because it was when we first needed
to know the time somewhere other than
where we were
yeah i made a whole video explaining
time zones and i go through the history
of them
oh so i don't have to cover that stuff
in this video that's gonna save a lot of
time
what video
uh
the one that i'm filming right now the
one you interrupted
oh i'm so sorry about that
uh hey before i let you go could you
tell your viewers to watch my video
explaining time zones when they're done
watching your video and tell them
they'll have a great time
watching it
i see what you did there yeah sure i'll
tell them
thank you
i'll catch you later or
until next time
oh boy okay bye matt
so yeah if you want to learn more about
the history and the politics of time
zones you should go on over to mr beat's
channel later on and check out his video
on the subject i put a link in the
doobly-doo to make things easy
anyway by this point people had given up
on the daily clock erections
from now on the sun didn't give us the
real time our clocks did
bow down
and we kept making better clocks
in 1927 the first quartz clock was built
at bell labs a huge improvement over
pendulum clocks
by 1939 it was accurate to within
.002 seconds per day by 1945 it was
accurate to
.00009 seconds per day that's one second
in 30 years
in the 1950s we saw the development of
atomic clocks which were eventually
accurate to the nanosecond
by the late 1960s even the general
conference of weights and measures had
given up on defining time by
astronomical motion
the second is now officially defined
as the duration of 9 billion 192 million
631
770 periods of the radiation
corresponding to the transition between
the two hyperfine levels of the ground
state of the cesium-133 atom
we've accepted that time doesn't care
where the sun is so why do we still care
why do we want noon to be when the sun
is highest in the sky
couldn't that just as easily be 1 pm or
11 am or 6 pm
we change this during daylight savings
time what difference does it make
why does sunrise need to happen at 6am
give or take a couple hours why couldn't
that happen at 6 pm or 2pm or am
this might sound crazy but hear me out
what if we completely got rid of time
zones
what if we had one world time
you could schedule a call with an
out-of-state friend or co-worker and say
i'll call you at 1 pm and it would be 1
pm for both of you
if you travel across the country you
could more easily stay on your regular
sleep schedule
i take daily medication which is a
nightmare when traveling yeah sure the
pill app says that it's going to adjust
for the time change but it never works
right like ever
seriously though everyone in the world
switches to utc that's universal time
coordinated then we're done we don't
ever switch the clocks ever again
if the sun rises around 7am in london
then it rises around noon in new york
city
if office jobs start at 9am in london
then they start at 2pm in new york city
instead of working five you just work
two to ten
it's still the daytime you just gotta
get used to the numbers
i honestly thought this was gonna be the
hottest of hot takes but there are a lot
of people in the comments of that poll
on board with this idea
unfortunately at the end of the day
people want their clocks to match the
sun so i'm not gonna hold my breath i
get it change is hard we're having a
hard enough time getting rid of the
semi-annual time change
these time zones are like a compromise
between where we should be going and
where we've been
i think getting rid of this mess would
be a sign that our concept of time was
finally growing up
anyway what do you think should time
zones exist or no get rid of them please
share in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to my generous
patreon patrons and youtube members like
owen o'sullivan who's been supporting at
the einsteinium level for over two years
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
dude are you okay now
yeah yeah i'm fine sorry
some of you thought an asteroid's worth
of dark matter in our solar system was a
bit sus
think of it this way a single building
weighs a lot more than the air inside
that building but the weight of the
entire atmosphere is 5 000 times the
weight of all human-made stuff combined
scale matters
anyway thanks for watching